what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Sakia so pumped to be
talking about quantum mechanics and
non-duality we have dr. Seth Cossack
joining us on the show hi Seth Aion
thank you very much for having me on
pleasure I'm so pumped and that was a
great last chat you had with Ori as well
I'm so pumped for our conversation for
those who don't know Seth's background
he's building a holographic
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
non-duality you can find his links in
the Bible Oh Seth costs tech comm also
his YouTube channel which has a lot of
epic content on it go subscribe and
check out those videos and then his
Twitter profile where he actually is
forced to compress the complexity of
this into 240 characters 280 now they
gave me an extra 40 is the update that I
needed that little leeway yeah all right
you guys I've had a great convoy I want
to start off with this idea of infinite
consciousness in this reality we find
ourselves embedded and why does it even
exist so because consciousness is
infinite it doesn't exist outside of
anything it is the totality of being
which is the only being that's here so
since it's infinite there can't be
anything other than it otherwise that
other nough something less than infinite
so if there is consciousness and
consciousness is infinite then it's all
that can be here okay and then why did
consciousness make this so the this that
you're referring to is infinite
consciousness mm-hmm you're just
misinterpreting it as the illusion of
the finite so okay so when I use the
word this I'm referring to this finite
universe that I'm
yeah so I mean if you're infinite
knowing what consciousness is knowing
it's a knowing being if you're an
infinite knowing being you already know
everything or you know there are no
things to know that you just know all so
you might want to do something else so
you might want to play some games okay
so all that is decided to make this game
yeah I use the word game I stole that
from Alan Watts so so a game is an
activity engage as a diversion or for
amusement
and so this infinite Ness see there's
only infinite consciousness here so it's
going to have to divert its attention
it's knowing from its own being to know
the illusion of something that appears
to be other than its infinite being so
you're you're ignoring yourself so that
you can play around and see the illusion
of things like this microphone that
appear to be other than yourself and
then you identify with certain content
within consciousness as yourself but
you're not that content you're the
knowing of it you do create it but it's
there is only your infinite totality
here so that's all that's here and the
game is the ignorance of your being okay
and I highly recommend for those that
haven't watched the interview with david
alexander english titled infinite
consciousness on our channel to check
that interview out david alexander
english says that the ultimate creation
of infinite consciousness is this game
where we can feel the illusion of
separation yeah so i would just say that
consciousness was never created it's all
that is it's infinite it never came from
anywhere diversion you called it yes so
the beam is occurring in consciousness
and as consciousness that's diverting
its attention from consciousness the
game appears to be created from our art
the illusion of our finite perspectives
but the game is part of infinite
conscious because it has to be because
if there is any being it has to be
consciousness it has to be part of that
information in tune it being so like
this conversation has to take place has
to because it would if it didn't it then
consciousness one it wouldn't be part of
consciousness but consciousness in it is
infinite so it must include this
conversation now we didn't have to
explore that conversation as a
determined image sound thoughts feelings
smells we don't have to explore it as
the illusion of finite it could be like
the blank behind me that's undetermined
blank there's nothing back there but if
I turn around and I direct my attention
I create interference that gives you the
illusion of content here so there's just
an issue with our physics in our
language where we conflate occurrence
and determination saying that this is
like causal no there's no such thing as
cause and effect it's an illusion
there's only consciousness and it's
activity of knowing complement the
composition of complimentary opposite
limits that give the appearance of
interference holographic interference
information that we take to be objects
outside of consciousness what we're just
looking at consciousness
we're misinterpreting it no
misinterpretation of perception is what
an illusion is you're you're looking at
the thing the thing is really there it's
just that thing is the infinite meaning
of consciousness that you're
misinterpreting so if people think
illusion means phantom or that it's not
really there no it's really there it's
right there this is microphone is right
there it's just consciousness you're
misinterpreting it for a microphone as
is yourself is consciousness so there's
really I can't say anything directly
about consciousness even these words are
all let's start from a first principle
to understanding of this conversation
okay so in the most first principled way
and then we'll get to the
preprint paper which i also want to talk
about what you were just saying I think
this is extremely important whereas in
many ways we believe that Big Bang
happened which then created evolution
which then created consciousness rather
than consciousness just being all that
is ok so let's start this first
principle of understanding so let's
start with as best as we can with words
that can describe what we're talking
about God or all that is or infinite
consciousness or all those all
synonymous yes so God would be
all-knowing right so are you knowing
these words that I'm saying right now so
that's knowing right so that knowing is
included in the infinite set of
all-knowing so you must be God so if God
is all-knowing and you're knowing these
words then you're gone now I don't like
to use the word God because it has
caught up with so many misunderstandings
and connotations there's nothing you can
say about it weasal God's not gods
there's only one God we are all God yeah
but this infinite knowing being that we
are is ignoring that infinite mist so so
Seth here is not conscious Allen is not
conscious this microphone is not
conscious it's made of it occurring in
it and known by consciousness as the
illusion of something other than
consciousness but there's only this
infinite consciousness here and this
consciousness is knowing with a capital
K is being with a capital B is truth
with a capital T because this knowing
being is what consciousness is and if
what is is being well what is is what
truth is truth isn't what isn't so truth
is this infinite totality which is a
singularity with a capital S which is
certainty knowing is not guessing
so certainty with a capital C
well this infinite knowing being truth
of consciousness this is the I that
you're referring to this is the I this
is what I is is knowing there is all all
synonymous you can call that God if you
want that's taken from like a religious
perspective but there's nothing you can
say about it these words are trying to
point to it but these words are still
part of the game
so like when neil has to go into the
matrix he has to go into the he can't be
outside the matrix and be in the matrix
he's got to use the matrix in the matrix
you're in the matrix of mind here I can
only use mind to describe the thing
that's making this infinite labyrinth of
your own mind that you're lost in you
you've you've forgotten who you really
are are walking around this labyrinth of
your own mind thinking it's physical
material objects outside of that mind
and I'm wondering oh man why does it
hurt when I stop by toe and why is this
so hard and why it's so difficult and
because consciousness is infinite you
can do whatever it wants but it wants to
know these limitations the purpose of
life right now is then okay if the this
consciousness is ignoring itself on
purpose then the purpose is to know
these limitations these limitations hurt
this is what suffering is this is what
pain the trials and tribulations of life
so this is the point is to play this
game and to feel this these feelings and
overcome they come together I mean this
infinite consciousness is only it so
there's no playmate for consciousness if
consciousness wants to know what it's
like to have a friendship to have a
dialogue it needs to ignore its in
Fitness create these illusions of
separation and then it can explore that
content all aspects to that are being
done inside of the game of infinite
consciousness are for learn
are for experiencing for being for truth
I would just say it's it's knowing so
like if I want to think about or guess
what it's like to climb the Himalayas I
have a little picture in my mind and oh
yeah I'd be tough and I need some oxygen
and I have like a mental but I don't
know it I have never actually done it in
experience so I can philosophize about
it I can guess about it but see when
consciousness wants to know something it
knows it it's doing it it's actually
knowing it from this finite perspective
so it's it's knowing so this is for this
infinite consciousness is for knowing a
myriad of different yeah it knows it's
know it so it's a singularity of
infinite potential infinite this so it's
abstracted it's being into every single
possible concept is knowing them as a
super entangled superposition of all
possible the Kurtz's simultaneous
simultaneous li happening it's all
simultaneously happening right now all
of it now part of the sum of those
concepts in that singularity they're
occurring are limits that prevent you
from seeing the entire singular totality
at one time so now you are knowing the
concept of Alan not equals Alan by
knowing the finite set of Alan you are
ignoring Seth you're ignoring all these
other perspectives and you've limited
yourself to just seeing through this one
perspective or knowing what that one
perspectives content that they see so
it's all occurring simultaneously but
you've limited yourself from the access
of those other concepts so you don't see
them you don't see all the other
potential paths through life
that you're currently simultaneously
living right now but you don't see
you've limited yourself to one
occurrence but they're all here
simultaneously so like this is the the
sister that chose to go on to be an
entrepreneur versus the set that chose
to continue working at a company or the
stuff that chose to have a child or not
have a child all these paths are
simultaneous all in infinite
consciousness at the same time in
quantum entangled States yes so if
you're familiar there's a theory about
them called the mini worlds it's a mini
world's the implementation of quantum
mechanics right they say that there are
these many worlds out there and at every
decision point there's a branching of
these universes into the universe
because though if your thought talking
infinite then there's that infinite is
so large that at every branching
decision yeah so here's the issue is
that that that that interpretation is
closed but it's been missed it because
see this isn't a world what do they mean
by the many worlds this isn't a world
this is a holographic conceptual
interference pattern that's all this is
that's what you're looking at and you've
limited that a holographic let's say for
that down okay yeah let's break that
down how do you want to break it down
okay
so let's go back to first principles so
the words that we can use again to
describe this reality all that is God
and infinite consciousness are these
words that we can use to describe the
the purpose of what is this happening is
for this infinite consciousness to know
or experience the illusion of something
other than its infinite being okay so
there is that okay - no or experience
something other than the it appears all
that appears other than other
it's infinite being okay all right so
that's what that's what the this that's
what this is and you don't call this a
creation you don't call these creations
you call these games well I I just think
game is an apt it is the creation it is
a it is it screen okay I mean it's the
ultimate it's what creates the illusion
of all things consciousness is what is
creating the illusion of all apparent
things okay so then we'll we'll stay
with that so that then that the creation
of the game is of these games the
creation or these games so we can use
maybe those words interchangeably as
well yes see the create see the thing is
it's not like I'm a person and I created
this little object over there the
creation is it's being yeah it is the
being that it is creating yeah yeah so
they're their assignment they're they're
they're one in the same
yeah yeah so that's the beauty of it see
you're not Alan and I'm not Seth we are
this experience of this little
conversation right now that's what we
are we're the knowing of this
conversation and the hum of the fan and
the lights were the knowing of this
experience that's what we are that's
what consciousness is is the knowing of
all of this so we've consciousness has
created it but it's not like chiseling
it out of clay or so if I of the
relation or the game is not happening
outside of infinite conscious rect yeah
yeah inside it's yes it out of it so
made of it so we have again infinite
consciousness god or can you also use
the word source or do not use that I
don't use it but you could use it I
guess I think that's what they're
pointing to right field theories and you
also use non duality of non-duality is
okay like interchanged with all that is
or than it conscious yes okay all right
so so right again we have non duality
infinite consciousness God source all
that is yes so we have these words that
are top let's say and
and then there is some sort of a game or
creation that happens inside of it which
is this experience or knowing of the of
the infinite consciousness of the
separation of it yes so this infinite
one totality right that's all that's
here so in order to ignore its infinite
totality it's got to somehow cause the
illusion of separation so how is it
going to do that because the only thing
here is knowing so the only tool that it
has is to know so how does it create
separation it creates a concept so a
concept con is against and cept is take
from from the Latin and so these
concepts appear as two dualistic
complimentary opposites made out of the
knowing that they're not each other so
that's how the illusion of duality
arises so you know I have consciousness
which is infinite and then this knowing
is knowing these opposites these
opposites do not appear with only one of
them I need both that are made literally
made up made out of each other so in
physical here you know oh position and
momentum like you can never know the two
at the same time why not
because they're made out of knowing
they're not each other so if I've cut
position over here I don't
I mean nori momentum like a momentum I'm
ignoring position let's we'll get to
that exact aspect of this as well so
okay so then this is some sort of a it's
a function of of infinite consciousness
to experience the knowing of the
illusion of separation yeah okay so now
we have those levels we have the first
words of the of what this is then we
have the perp then we have the creation
of the game and for the purpose that we
just listed
so we're there and we have that that's
this first these first principles okay
now we are here now now this now this
physical so that kind of gives people
the explanation that we were talking
about earlier where many times it seems
like Oh a Big Bang evolution then
consciousness but no it's actually
consciousness and then game creating the
game that were yes it's conscious in
this game this did the knowing of
opposites is common the common parlance
is mind so the mind is the knowing of
these offices so it it's consciousness
then it plays this game of knowing
opposites so it's conscious then this is
the mind and then this mind when you
interfere these concepts together then
you get the illusion of objects yeah so
it's the exact opposite of material
physicalism yeah yeah yeah the exact we
just flip it yeah and so I'm also not
the one that I mean I see this from a
physical standpoint but the the person
that's way more eloquent than me because
he's English English his rupert Spira so
yeah that's to you if anyone is out
there that really you know if I'm sound
confusing
Rupert's not confusing he's a surgical
linguist yeah he knows what he's got it
he understands yeah I love that's
actually so so important okay so not
like consciousness comes 13.8 billion
years later in a civilization but
consciousness is the first the most
first principled on this bar her at
farthest side well it's a fundamental
funny because it's all that's here okay
that's good all right now you know now
let's get into what you were just
describing earlier so now we have this
you use these words knowing being truth
so singularity is also another word that
describes what we were talking about
earlier at the highest level of all that
is God's source create okay okay so then
alright great now knowing being truth so
what is what
what are we are we talking about a
feeling of knowing of being of truth are
we talking about that feeling of knowing
the infinite consciousness of being the
infinite consciousness of that being the
truth that we feel that now I would say
feeling as content so so what is than
what is yet then knowing is not limited
so you can't grasp it it's not a feeling
a thought it's not an image it's not a
smell it's making the illusion of all
that content so you're you you're not
it's not graspable this is what see
perspectives knowing through the mind
want to try to grasp it as an object
because the mind can only see things in
terms of opposites this is what logic is
so I can only know this because I know
that this is not that so I'm trying to
grasp infinite consciousness as an one
of these limits but consciousness is the
thing that's knowing the limits to grasp
consciousness I would have to know this
that simultaneously which is a
superposition of limits you can't know
that you you can't grasp it touch your
touch this that thing well which thing
did you this one or that one
you you can't grasp it it's not grasp so
these feelings are content their content
occurring in consciousness how do we how
do we gain then knowing or experience of
infinite consciousness of God of all
that is how do we gain your knowing it
right now okay so this is all your no no
it by being your knowing it right now
this is it okay so we got it right here
you got it you already it okay but you
don't see it that way do you you think
your alan i want to know also how
science can then do the scientific
method and probe at this hypothesis that
okay yeah this is precisely what we need
to talk about so here here's the here's
the issue so you have to know how
science works right so if you're gonna
use there are different pisum illogical
tools that you can use to try to probe
experience so the first is religion
which justified so again
these words that I'm talking these are
limited they're not what's actually here
they're made out of dualistic opposites
so these words are not the truth nothing
I'm saying is is true these are
conceptually true beliefs within a
belief system so when you understand
that all we have here are statements
that we've accepted I mean you were born
right was the word world already here
when you were born did you hear about it
and then say yeah this is the world well
then that's a belief that's a statement
you've accepted describing this infinite
consciousness you you accept that now
you have a belief oh yeah this is the
world I'm a human did you invent the
word human did you do an experiment to
figure out that you're a human being
no she bears told you you're a human
being you say yeah I am so you've got
beliefs here there's nothing but beliefs
and then now we have to figure out which
beliefs are justified in which they're
just an opinion
okay so works where we're ascribing
language to beliefs and then then that
is in a sense than creating some sort of
a way both for us to describe the things
that are that we're gauging with but
also it's a limit little limitation yes
it's a limitation on infinite
consciousness and then you think this is
a finite object so so you've got these
beliefs and then now you've got to
figure out how do I know which ones are
valid so this is the study of
epistemology it's the just it's it's the
study of what's justify truth versus
belief yeah justified opinion versus I
justified belief versus opinion so we
only got believes here which ones are
are valid okay well we've got religion
which justifies belief with belief we
you're a human and that's true because I
believe it's true it's a statement I've
accepted and I believe that statement
that's a religious belief okay and
you've got philosophy
which uses logic to justify police you
got to start with a belief and so all
your logic is an infinite chain of
causal action you've got to terminate
that chain somewhere so okay I'll
terminate it the Big Bang there was a
budding bang that's a belief it's a
statement I wasn't around I didn't
actually experience it so I should hit
something I accepted that statement Big
Bang was here before I was born and I
heard about then I accepted it okay so
that's a belief I got that and now I run
my causal chain forward it makes the
universe and all the stuff and stars and
humans and planets and all that so now
I've got a logical causation that's a
philosophy of how this thing occurred
it's not justified by logic so you've
got this whole material physicalist
paradigm that there was universe and
evolution and all the stuff and now
that's how I'm here as a human being I
was born my parents conceived me that's
how I'm here
okay well that's beliefs justified by
logic okay well now science is different
because it justifies our beliefs the
experience yeah
now experience was one of our words yeah
consciousness truth experience so this
experience not the concept of experience
not equals experience experience the
totality of experience the infinite
occurrence of what is happening that is
what truth that's where science goes to
justify its beliefs it justifies its
beliefs in infinite truth itself
that's why science is so powerful so
science doesn't have nothing to do with
beliefs it's intimately intertwined with
beliefs and logic mm-hmm but the arbiter
in science is experience so science
starts with a belief you perform a
logically constrained test of that
belief performed in the actuality of
knowing experience you actually have to
do an experiment experiment in science
for it to be science yeah it's for it to
be justified by science yeah so
theoretical physics is not science it's
philosophy
then when you do the experiment you have
to interpret the results through your
limited perspective mm-hmm you write it
down
you publish your paper now someone reads
the paper
what are they got they got a belief out
again because accepting the statements
in that paper even though they're
justified by experience they're trying
to pew pew review it yeah which would
then create more experience the the the
the I'm talking about the there's only
experience so yeah people reading the
police and stuff is experience but when
you get out of the paper is a statement
that you've accepted so it stars with
beliefs and it ends with beliefs but the
arbiter of the experiment was
experienced yes and then the point of
that is when you say things like
infinite consciousness the question is
how do you know and then the follow-up
to that is okay we're using science to
conduct experiments for experiencing
that so so over time you can maybe peer
review things and get more and more
people around the world that have this
they use the scientific method to
experience infinite consciousness or to
understand it better well here you're
all you're going to only get believes
still so even if you read these papers
but what's gonna happen is you're
touching the truth right with every
experience so more and more of it rubs
off on a science right over time over
time we get closer and our models get
better right Newton could only do so
much stuff cuz his science only
described was able to limit
consciousness in a certain way but as we
get quantum mechanics and relativity
well now are powerful right we can
unlock the unbelievable power of what we
believe to be atoms we split these atoms
and the power of God comes right out of
there
so when you start to touch the truth of
experience you become more and more
powerful
because you're becoming more and more
infinite you're getting closer and
closer to that truth so well what
happens is then you you you can start to
design experiments or reinterpret
experience and then see ah how science
it proves scientifically through
experience that you're in a conscious
singularity okay perfect
how do we use science to prove that
we're in a conscious singularity okay so
this is written in my favor yes okay so
let's uh let's also give the let's give
the the title visual perception mediated
by light traversing 4d space-time
continuum is an illusion so the double
slit experiment proving non-duality
correct that's what happens okay so yeah
okay so so the issue you're gonna have
is that it's just better if you've never
heard about the double slit experiment
at all
because the double slit experiment is
contextualized under the paradigm of
material physicalism and this experiment
breaks that paradigm it shatters it so
if you go into knowing about the double
slit experiment and oh there's particles
and waves and there's light traversing
space-time you've got a huge mountain to
climb because none of that is current
there is no light traversing any slits
in the double slit experiment
there's only consciousness knowing the
illusion of this content that gives rise
to the your fares better so let's just I
don't know how I want to start this so
basically what the double slit
experiment really is is an assay of
visual perception so you have a field of
view right now okay so this is when
we're gonna get to the visual perception
but we were talking about before a
little bit on the show and also before
a banana that's a kind of a noisy which
isn't like the mics in the shot sure but
the bananas something you also um eat
which is something that yeah okay so we
got a bit in here yeah how do you salary
sing that banana let me go let me go get
the banana I'll be right up your banana
I don't know what you were thinking
about you I mean we're going bananas
here right I think this is this is uh a
little joke I love all right I love all
so here
here are bananas here's our Apple let's
go with let's go with let's go we hope
so what a lot of people do is they go
into concepts in beliefs right when
they're talking about the double-slit
experiment they're not talking from
actuality so are are you seeing a banana
this is a banana I mean you handed me a
banana so you're using a banana well
we're using that too I'm saying yeah are
you say I'm just asking you a question
are you learn conceptualising our
environment get all this stuff is our my
seeing a banana yes okay great so you're
seeing a banana so now the question is
how is that occurring how are you seeing
this yeah yeah soso so we've got this
belief okay I'm seeing a banana from
light that's interacted with it it's
your first base time enter my eyes that
light information is converted into
biological signals that my variant
processes the forms a known image in the
mind that consciousness is then knowing
and then knowing of that known image
determines the existence of the physical
banana that's what like immediate
perception States yeah
so I mediated perception as well yeah so
the theory of light immediate perception
so yeah you have to then understand like
okay because that belief true is that
logical chain of reasoning is that
correct is that how it really works it's
just a belief you you heard
you were seeing objects like shining
well for millions of years we have
decided that that that is a banana and
that we've been passing that down yeah
so but the idea that you're seeing from
light right this is also a belief right
so that we're seeing from light making
the neurobiological segments that we're
interpreting with an image of the past
and then our consciousness thisis a
banana yeah okay so we found out that
that logical chain of reasoning from
these beliefs is philosophy okay so what
we're here to do is science mm-hmm so we
need to do an experiment okay we need to
do an experiment the tests vision so how
the heck are we gonna do that because
vision is topologically bound so this
banana behind me right now it's probably
all frame - no it's in right I'm not
knowing an image of it right hmm so the
image of the banana is undetermined now
I bring it into my determined field of
view and I see it so we go from
undetermined to determined so what we
got to do is break the topology of our
vision I've got to get that undetermined
Blanc behind me into my visual field
shine light on it okay no you don't have
you don't have to this is just a okay
just you just take your camera you put
it in selfie mode right okay so this is
I take light I have to shine it on let's
uh let's show let's show the show the
viewers all right so here's the here's
that here's it's in selfie mode yo so
there's an image of the banana on the
screen right yeah there is okay so what
we have to do okay I don't even need
this thing so this is going to be my
detector so what we need is an object
that's undetermined we've got to break
the topology we got to bring that
undetermined blank into our fill of you
shine light on it mm-hmm let that light
traverse space-time and then I need a
photon detector
that can also display the image that it
snowing so this is a perceiver right
uh-huh
got it so like you're a PC or you're
perceiving but this perceiver special
because I can perceive the perception
that procedure is receiving yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I love dr. Seuss right yeah
yeah so in this sense I see what you're
seeing what's out that's why you did the
front-facing camera yeah that your
should we're seeing what the
front-facing camera is perceiving yes so
this is what we have to do to ask a
visual perception I've got to take all
of the elements of visual perception
okay put them in my visual field of view
and then look to see what happens yes so
okay so the claim of light media visual
perception is that light shining on
undetermined objects determines known
images of them known images like the
image of the banana on the screen here
had a one-to-one fixed correspondence to
the oddity producing it there was one
banana here and there's one banana on
the screen it's a known image right
knowing known images tells me there are
known objects there I can look at the
known image reach my hand out and I get
confirmation oh there's a physical
material object there because I'm
looking at the known image mmm okay so
okay you see the problem we have that's
one that's light mediated perception
that you just stated yeah so so how do I
get the blank behind me into my
determine field of view because I can't
turn my head around fast enough every
time I turn my head around the blank
falls behind it right it's it's
complimentary opposed I can never get
that undetermined into my visual field
of view so I could shine light on it so
that I could see if I see a known image
okay so well if you start to think about
determining undetermined you realize
that space time empty space time is a
determined undetermined so the one more
time with all this so it's it's it's
undetermined because it's not in my
field of perception and then when it's
in my field it is well if I have
somebody standing up behind you
I tell them to hold up
a number of fingers how many fingers are
they holding up no idea because you
can't determine it yeah
now you turn around and look yeah oh
three fingers yeah did you've determined
it okay it's known got four it was
unknown and now it's known okay and then
what and then now we're trying to make a
scientific experiment so now we're just
trying to make a science of experiment
to see because light media perception it
claims that shining light on
undetermined objects determines their
existence in by knowing a known image of
them by knowing it right now what is
behind them is undetermined okay
until you look there's light shining on
it but it's being blocked by the back of
my head I turn around and I look at that
light to stream into my eyes and then
now I know unknown image and this is
determined it's a known of anything yeah
and in the art of the argument is that
it is always known it is infinite
consciousness is always known but then
we need a scientific method to I just
need to do an experiment okay in
experience that proves it so yeah I've
got to do that I've got it that that
that belief system that you have there
that you're shining light on objects and
you're determining known images of them
well that's belief in philosophy
I need us experiment I need to prove it
I need to do it in experience I can make
up any philosophical argument I want but
it's just BS until I actually do the
experiment then I find out the truth
okay okay so we've got to construct an
undetermined object eat our fill of you
so that we can shine light on it and
then capture that light information on
the screen so you know this is a
determined field of view there are known
images and then there are these voids
where they're the known images are
objects physical material objects and
the the voids are determined that there
are no objects there so there are no
objects here because there's no known
images so if I hold up my two fingers
right you're knowing known images of
those two
projects but are you knowing an own
image of the empty space time between
the two fingers what's the image can you
draw it for me of this empty space is
there an own image there yes or no a
bunch of oxygen and nitrogen are you
seeing you draw me oxygen so there are
known images of these objects that
you're knowing but in the empty space
when light passes through an empty
space-time where there are no objects
then there's not a known image there
there's the lack of a known image so
it's transparent that way you can see
through to the background you can't see
through the background where the objects
are occurring because there's an own
image that blocks out the background
okay but where there is no known image
okay the knowing of not a known image
that tells you that there's no objects
there and then you can see through the
background and now you're knowing that
know an image okay okay so light
traversing space-time producing not a
non image determines that there are no
existing objects there nothing exists
there this is key the lack of a known
image the knowing of not a known image
determines that there are no existing
objects okay so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna shine light on our
undetermined object and if let's just
say the undetermined object was these
two fingers so you shine light on it and
if you saw ten fingers with that ten
finger image that you're knowing be a
known image or not a known image so I'm
holding up two there's two fingers but
you're seeing ten is that ten finger
image that you're knowing an image that
has a one-to-one fixed correspondence to
the object producing it no no so if I'm
holding up two fingers and you're seeing
ten you're hallucinating because you're
knowing the appearance of something
that's not actually present
hallucinations don't occur outside of
consciousness they occur inside of
consciousness
they're made of consciousness right okay
so we've got to create our this isn't
your time but like the interference
pattern is what okay
so we've got to create an object that we
can shine light on that's undetermined
so if I've got determined undetermined
voice right the objects in here have a
shape a defined form but the space as I
move this as I move these objects to get
this space in between see it's like an
amoeba it changes shape the fists don't
change their shape the space is they
determined undetermined it's an always
changing ever amoeba-like void so if I
take space-time space-time right here
and I start to limit it I start putting
constraints on it and I limit it I can
make an object called
a hole now I got an object and if I got
my hole here and I shine light on it I
get an image of a hole no problem okay
but we know the holes determined because
there's no other place for the light to
go if I have a this hole in a barrier I
block out all the other light the light
has to go through that hole otherwise
there would be no illumination at all
okay but again we need to undetermined
object now to determine one so for
clever what we can do is put two slits
side by side now I cannot determine
which slit the light goes through so now
when I shine light on this undetermined
object do I get a known image that has a
one-to-one fixed correspondence to the
two slits you would see two yeah oops
bit too light that's what you said you
got two holes you should see two two
lines on it on there you go you don't
you see ten fingers you see a
distributed line patterns whose slits
make ten or more or any kind of the
configuration but they create what is
commonly referred to as an interference
pattern
you know it's not but that's what they
call it and it's the lack of
interferences what you're seeing that
pattern is the lack of interference so
it's the lack of interference so when we
put the banal when we easy we we have we
have to there's a lot that we have to
talk about before I talk about lack of
interference so that's got to be that's
like maybe 30 minutes from now Soho so
here's the thing is the crux of the
whole experience the whole thing is you
have two objects or an undetermined
object of two slits you can't determine
which light to select the light goes
through and when you shine light on that
undetermined object you don't get a
known image that determines it okay so
when you turn around you are not knowing
the image behind you from light that's
shown on it because we just proved light
shining on undetermined objects does not
determine them okay so now here's the
mind-blowing part okay here's the
mind-blowing following so far so this
this seemingly non super controversial
double slit experiment actually is quite
controversial because they could
potentially null our way of what we
initially thought was the light mediated
perception correct which is a massive
deal yes is huge this is the whole thing
everything this is the most important
experiment in the history of mankind so
Wow your issue this pictures this is it
yeah so Richard Feynman properly said
the entire mystery of the universe is in
this experiment the mystery of the
entire universe is in this one
experiment yeah and here it is you shine
light on an undetermined object it's not
determinate so you turn around that
image is not determined from light to
China okay now when you are knowing ten
figures from two when you are knowing
not a known image then the object imaged
does not exist
or or to exists in a in a different way
that's creating what is your doesn't
exist outside of consciousness it's
being in consciousness as a
hallucination so when light traverses an
empty space-time like between the two
fingers and there are no objects that
exist there you know not an own image
when you see the distributed line
pattern the cannot canonically referred
to as an interference pattern you are
knowing not a known image therefore that
slit object does not exist why does it
make it so that the slit object doesn't
exist why isn't it just that there's
something about the way that we're
seeing an interference pattern rather
than just - you're seeing this banana
yeah you're knowing a known image of it
that known image is telling you that the
banana exists right mm-hmm so what if
you were seeing this banana but was 80
bananas here but it wasn't light
mediated perception that's right there's
no light medium perception what is it if
it's not light media perception
consciousness so what this experiment
reveals is that these slits and like
everything they're attached to is
occurring in consciousness as
consciousness there is no cause in
effect you could shine light all day
long on an undetermined object it never
causes a known image in order to get a
known image in order to change that
distributed line pattern to two lines I
have to put in an apparatus behind the
double slit experiment that it converts
the photons that go through it into
multiple photons that then I can know
which path they took through slit a or B
or I could erase that information and
when I do that what happens well now
it's no longer undetermined I've
determined it because I am knowing which
slit the light goes through
knowing consciousness is determining
which slit so determination doesn't
occur from light shining on things
determination occurs from knowing
knowing the composition of concepts and
it turns out you need four limits or the
men at minimum two concepts to know the
illusion of any finite content and this
is what the double studies and
experiments telling you you've got this
concept of photon not equals photon x
known slit unknown slit and when you
have a photon x a known slit you get two
lines when you have a photon x an
unknown slit you get distributed pattern
the lines and the reason is is that this
concept structure is asymmetric so I
have the illusion of a finite set of
potential here made out of knowing that
it's not the infinite totality of
consciousness it's an infinite set on
this side if I have the concept of the
number 1 not equals the number 1 1
appears as a finite set and it's made
out of knowing that it's not two not
three not four not every other number so
this infinite conceptual set is not
limiting it's infinite so it doesn't
restrict which slit the light goes
through it's it's interfering with that
concept and if your knowing the entire
concept all at the same time it's hard
to talk about this it's easier to draw
it or something but this you know did I
think another way maybe for this to then
make sense is from a way of us
perceiving in just in general so when
when we're talking about infinite
consciousness being everything all that
is God this is a very first principle
thing we were talking about there is no
separation between me and you me and
this microphone
in this Apple correct there's no
separation it's all consciousness okay
then the then the next thing would be to
say something along the lines of then
the way that that like with a double
slit experiment or with the way that
we're talking about this Apple is that
if it's all if it's all infinite
consciousness then I have to kind of do
some sort of of what we were talking
about this before we started some sort
of like an ebb and flow in
that happens that I go from being in
this infinite consciousness state to
being like okay this is an apple because
I am hungry and I need to eat this Apple
to gain nourishment so then that process
is in some sense like a like an epic and
flowing between those two things so when
you take something like a double slit
experiment it's like when you're trying
to do it and you're trying to prove that
oh this is this is an this is a two-slit
supposed to be too but instead it's a 10
into this interference pattern that we
see you were - what we're trying to do
is we're trying to say I want to eat
this Apple in that study versus saying
that it's all consciousness this is at
least that's the best that I could do
with my limit yeah the thing is both are
true simultaneously so it's all infinite
consciousness and you are knowing the
illusion of separation and they're
happening simultaneously right on top of
each other but you're paying attention
you're not understanding that this is
infinite conscious okay so the infinite
consciousness and the illusion of
separation are happening simultaneous
simultaneously and then that's why in
like the double slit experiment you're
seeing both of those things you're
seeing the you're see you're you you're
saying that there is that infinite
consciousness but we're perceiving it as
some sort of like illusion of separation
of photons and interference patterns
yeah so this experiment proves is is
there's no such thing as perception
because there's nothing perception means
to know something through the senses but
there's no light going into your eyes
you see so there is no such thing as
perception it's
totally Falls it's an illusion you think
it's perception you think there's light
traversing space-time going to your eyes
or you think your have tactile feeling
sure there's no senses here that's an
illusion you you you ignore what's
actually going on
and then you just think that you're this
human being that's sensing on this world
because then we're embedded in the
immersion of of separation when we're
saying that there's a tactile yeah I
mean a way to think about this but I
need to know tactile because I don't
want to burn myself so yours yeah you
don't want to know the knowing of a
stovetop yeah yeah that yeah
that mean it does not good not good I
mean it's there's nothing wrong with it
but you might have a pain I don't want
to know that knowing you don't want to
know that pain yeah yeah but notice that
a child doesn't innately know that right
you hasn't experienced it so it doesn't
know what that is that's what you have
to prevent children putting their hands
on the stove they don't know it's hot
they don't know they're gonna burn
themselves they burn themselves now they
know so that's also a little like blank
slate versus like lineage if evolution
was baked into the child's mind yeah way
to think about this and it I kind of
like this way so you can either think of
like a movie reel an old-time movie
you're going on a theater and there's a
movie and there's 24 actual frames per
second right it's all in this big tin
can
so let's just say the beginning of that
movie was your life you were born in the
end of the movies your death and it
looks when you're when you put this film
in the projector the laser light of the
projector right the light of knowing is
shining through each film as the film
scrolls through it and you look at the
projection and you think oh yeah
Harrison Ford is moving around on the
screen he's Harrison before moving it no
he's not moving anywhere there's static
frames
that's what's really here this
interference film of concepts is what's
really here and then it's just the the
motion of the projector they makes it
appear that things are moving around
here but there's only this interference
film of concept yeah so like the that's
what yeah so so this is where holography
comes in okay so you also said that also
as you get into holography you said this
just needing to reiterate how important
it is that there is no perception the
double slit experiment proves that there
is no perception there's no perception
there's no light media you know
triceraton space time there's no lights
going through the slits because see if
everything's in consciousness and
consciousness is infinite dimensional
and singularity there's nothing moving
anywhere right how can you move in no
distance in no time you can't there's no
such thing so okay and then a whole log
Rafi yeah yeah so the thing is is okay
how do you describe and infinite
dimensionless singularity yeah yeah
you're way to do it right so the only
way I can describe it is to find a
conceptual singularity so black holes
trillions of black holes out those are
conceptual singularities there are
content occurring in consciousness that
is a point list dimensionless infinite
point right matter energy you know fall
into a black hole and then at the bottom
there's a singularity or where there's
dqo is infinite nothing can really be
said of this thing right okay so there
are a lot of arguments about this
because yeah what happened you you throw
something a black hole and the black
hole evaporates and you lose the
information you can have a problem with
the physics where you lose information
so how what are you gonna do so
brilliant there's a lot of brilliant
scientists on this so that can steam
and this was done in the 70s in Hawking
and Fanta toughed and busou and Susskind
these guys are you know yeah these are
great guys yeah it's just around the
corner so you should have him on your
show I know he's cool
no it's a little crotchety but he's cool
he's cool he's like a grandpa I love him
so these guys are cool and so what
they've done has are say okay well if
you drop information is real black all
the information has to be there
somewhere or where is it and so they
came up with this mathematics that
describes black hole thermodynamic
entropy so information
it's information theory and so they've
come up with this bekenstein Hawking
equation that describes a conceptual
singularity okay so now you can use that
to describe the actual singularity of
consciousness this description of
consciousness is still wrong you can't
there's nothing finite about
consciousness this is not a correct
theory you can't have a correct theory
you can't have a finite theory that
describes the infinite it's impossible
because that theories occurring in the
infinite so you would need something
outside of it to describe the theory
that's occurring within it so you can't
do it it's bound but you can come close
right we keep refining this right so we
get closer and closer and closer so this
theory is pretty cool because it brings
quantum mechanics and general relativity
together in one equation the entirety of
physics the entire explanation
everything is right in that equation and
if you substitute conceptual singularity
so the a conceptual singular is like a
black hole out there right you get
sucked in you like can't escape it right
that's a conceptual same thing this year
this experience this will come this is
an actual an actual singular the actual
singularity of consciousness
yeah contains black holes yeah okay as
concepts yeah conceptual interference so
that's this is what's happening so the
cool thing is that was the equation that
was the bekenstein
yeah
talking Becca Steen Hawking equation
which describes what happens
thermodynamically so it explains the
geometric information content of a black
hole of a black hole okay and that you
said that that bridges together quantum
mechanics and general relativity yes and
information theory and information
theory so Claude Shannon way long ago
you know showed that how you can
mathematically describe information and
it's the same as Gibbs entropy formula
interesting so what you do is you just
substitute the kid's injury formula into
the Mexican Hawking equation and then
you get this little equation that shows
you how limits of potential four of them
some together and then composited
together give rise to the illusion of
this content give rise to these little
frames of your movie yeah so this is
like a again getting back to the
projector so now think of your instead
of like the movie frame let's talk about
a hologram so we'll replace our movie
with a hologram yeah so we've got a
laser light now and it's got this
interference film it's this interference
pattern of concepts it's shining through
this film and then it projects this
entire illusion of a three-dimensional
hologram that you take to be real or a
reality or physical and material so
infinite consciousness is using
holography to make infinite
consciousness is knowing concepts as it
shines its laser light of knowing
through this hyper plane like event
horizon holographic film of concepts it
produces the illusion of a holographic
image that you take to be the physical
material world
so so infinite consciousness is
all-knowingness
uses creates the illusion of separation
world that were in
yeah so the the it is a holographic yes
holographic in nature it so the
interesting thing about this little
movie or this you know if we go back to
our movie analogy is that your path that
you're on if you look back at it right
you would see that if you watch the
entire movie from the beginning at the
end it's just one film in the
interference pattern again that infinite
consciousness is as creat is creating as
illusion of separation world through
that interference pattern is what again
its its concepts its concepts this is
all knowingness is shining through
concept concepts to make this
holographic illusion of separation yeah
and and what Kant what are the concepts
that it's there every abstraction every
pair of opposites that consciousness is
knowing every pair of opposites
complimentary opposites so I only know
what this is by knowing it's not not
equals this I only know what up is by
knowing what not just does that start
with some sort of a more maybe like
simple source code that then becomes
more and more complex over time I don't
know what you mean about that because
there's only good like could the
interference pattern of concepts that
you talked about could that have a very
very initial simple amount of of just
simplicity to the concepts that then as
it evolves it it becomes as the
holography evolves that then that
initial simplicity could becomes more
and more complex of these concepts the
concepts become more and more complex
but they're initially baked into a very
simple interference pattern of cause I
mean how I would answer that is no
because yes consciousness is infinite
it's it's the the only being that's here
and this game of knowing these concepts
has to be part of its infinite being
yeah at all times basically the the
question is more so that in this
interference pattern of concepts it
doesn't know it all as you're saying yet
the question is about if then over just
time of what has happened in this game
of the illusion if those have evolved
where there's more concepts that have a
fall so here's the thing so the whole
and this is what I was trying it to with
your with the life yes so you let's just
say you've got this life it's this film
it's one film cancer you stretch it out
you stretch it out you lay it on the
driveway and you can see the entire
thing all simultaneously online like 80
years of 24 frames a second usually just
looking at you can look at you can yeah
you can look at the whole film up the
whole time you could even look at our
whole time we wrapped up in the canister
right you can see the whole thing all at
once it doesn't look like this right it
doesn't look like watching the movie
it looks like the film canister right
okay now the thing is is because it's
infinite at every cell in the film you
have an infinite number of choices yeah
in every direction yes so now not only
do you have one film canister in one
path in life that you could take all of
these you have an infinite number of
film canisters yes
for every frame yes yes so now this
becomes impossible to think about you
can't even yeah I can't even like okay
this is it crazy so so you and
interestingly enough like I was
mentioning too before we started whoo
I'm excited to hear you potentially talk
to clear when have a very similar
conceptual understanding of that
specific thing because clearer when
talks about it like a massive kelp
forest and that you have this massive
massively tall piece of kelp and then
each little tiny moment in time with 24
frames per second let's say is like a
big is a
card in this big deck of cards that is
as tall as like a piece of kelp and that
when you go it out like that like this
big film canister you were describing
that then you see that each one of those
moments in time that those frames like
on the film canister is a deck of cards
each one of those is there's so many
ways to take this but that it's a
beautiful gift even if even if there's
like a little traumatic thing that's
dealt there that there's still some sort
of a treasure that comes from that
that's a slightly separate thing but
that that that one piece of kelp like
you were just describing has an infinite
amount of that was so that so this way
is horizontal or this vertical I'm sorry
vertical and then there's an infinite
amount of horizontals in in every
direction from each frame and then and
then so that is very fractal so it's
like this fractal and the way to
describe that it's like is you know just
the fact that we were using you know
banana and an apple and I didn't grab
the orange but I could have easily
grabbed the orange as well so that's a
frame in this in that projector film
that you're talking about that it could
have grabbed the orange and so that in
the many-worlds and sometimes can
interpret it as there is an Allen
talking to a Seth with an Ori that are
that grab the orange instead of grab the
Apple that's happening all at the same
time right it happened from the
beginning of everything is it's always
been there in there and so the other
issue is that it's probabilistic so you
are infinite potential your knowing lit
the illusion of limited potential and
then these potentials constrain the
concepts that you have access to so
right now since you didn't grab the
orange and so that's not gonna get out
of a seat he's constrained from knowing
touching an orange right now hmm
see this occurrence there's no orange
here for Seth to touch so he can't touch
it he's constrained conceptually
and so the concepts constrain each other
to potential to pop probabilities so
when you look into what this whole thing
is and you're like oh I thought it was a
thing I thought this was physical and
material mm-hmm quantum mechanics is
telling you the only being here that we
can describe our limited events
uncertain limited probabilities that's
what it's saying uncertain limited
probabilities like concepts and
relationships
yeah there's you could say there's only
relationship because there's only
there's only these events only
relationship yeah there's only these
events here so there aren't things like
this this microphone isn't a microphone
object physical thing it's microphone
it's conscious microphone conscious
microphone that's Apple Apple Inc
conscious Appling or Apple Inc this is
also from Alan Watts so he's like no
you're it's it looks physical and Static
right but if you are looking under the
under the physicalist perspective who
think that these things are atoms and
stuff you would see molecules bouncing
off is it's dancing right you just don't
see that you're limited you've limited
your psyche we were talking about the
oxygen nature yeah you're limited you
don't see that yeah okay but see you
dance these oxygen and these atoms and
these molecules they're concepts they're
not physical material things so you're
gonna last you laugh your ass off I mean
I love Stern in everything and I love
science and I we should play all you
want but they built a forty billion
dollar knife hmm let's cut that Apple in
half I you know for nine ninety five you
can get against you or something right
hmm okay well now we're gonna have a
knife that we have to have a knife
that's edge is so sharp yeah I need wood
11 terror electron volts or something
right and it's gonna cost me 40 billion
dollars and I'm gonna start cutting
these atoms in half but there you're
just splitting concepts and there but
they're also not like a knife because
they're doing collisions which then is
what the knife thing is you're cutting
yeah the mind is the illusion of cutting
cutting
mine cuts yeah yeah cuts in the illusion
of separation in order to know this over
here I've got to know it's not that it's
not that so I got to cut these atoms
okay I'll keep going I gotta cut these
bozos all right okay wait a minute guys
wake up what are you doing what are you
doing I mean I love it I love the
playing of it but you know a couple
billion dollars to help comes out for
some Hut because they're hungry would be
cool too right so we've got a we've
we've got our priorities in a weird way
from this ignorant of what is actually
here and the cool thing Richard Fineman
people should really study him yeah and
read his stuff because it's like he's
blatantly says no quantum physics does
not describe these objects
it describes events these aren't objects
so these are events not objects in
conscious yes so just when people hear
the word object they think physical
material yeah when I say the word object
I mean objective qualities something
with the illusion of edges or boundaries
yeah so that you can grab it yeah so the
mind is not in here consciousness is not
in here
the mind is out here this is the mind
right here yeah you're touching the mind
of God right now yeah you're in the mind
of God right now right yeah that's what
this is you know it's this labyrinth you
got to find your way out or not get lost
in here yeah
and finding your way out is about
learning concepts like this and then
learning the infinite consciousness I
think finding your way out might be this
chaos at the end of time here right this
this insanity that we seem to find
ourselves in this the oceans are boiling
the atmosphere is being fried the things
are being polluted overpopulation racial
tensions people protesting in every city
in all the streets right now this thing
is going it's like it's um there's like
some sort of emergence of something here
yeah some things happen
yeah people call it the singularity or
whatever but artificial intelligence
it's not intelligent consciousness is
the only intelligence here so the only
intelligence here it's not just it's
fair to say this is all pants I kissed
pants psychism everything is
consciousness
I think pants psychism refers to the
things being conscious there are no
things here that apples not conch I
think you can also refer to all is
consciousness like infinite psychism and
you mean all only consciousness or
sinfulness then that's totally cool but
i think they say like all just trees
it's got his treat consciousness and
there's an apple consciousness and this
rock concept i don't have access to the
rock consciousness but know that is
theirs
you can't have two conscious shirt
surfer because of one consciousness
would limit the other one so there can't
be two because it's infinite yeah so
there can only be a conscious being here
yeah so you don't have your
consciousness that doesn't have a
conscious said that's not conscious
there's only consciousness so we get
over our selves with that idea of this
is not I am NOT conscious it is all
conscious yeah and you don't really get
over it because this is a shock like
this is not something you can just
easily swallow like you're sitting here
and yeah you're having this little
conversation here and you know this is
cool when this hit me I fell to the
floor I mean what hi he's I'm looking at
the double cell expand I'm like okay
this is this image is not known and it's
not on though it's not known but the
object is unknown but this is not a
known image it's not known it's not
unknown it's not known what is left
knowing it's knowing that interference
pattern you're looking directly at
knowing that's not limited to a slit
you're seeing the entire concept of
photon I equals one time ones
oh my it blew me away I cried shoot a
puddle of tears it just was on the floor
just like oh my god
and so that statement by niels bohr if
you are not shocked by quantum mechanics
then you don't understand it because if
you really understood this you'd be on
the floor right now just like I was
it's that shocking so it's not so easy
to accept because then you realize that
the identity of set that I held that I
love that's just content in
consciousness Seth isn't here as a
conscious being only consciousness is
consciousness is conscious and that's
all that's here that's what you find out
and it's a shocker because you've lived
your entire parent life believing that
you are this content you've identified
with it but look what's happening
identity nowadays is getting distorted
or we're questioning it
we're playing identity politics
different pronouns and things what is
this what why are we doing this now ah
maybe it's a way for consciousness to
show like no you you weren't the gender
you thought you were you're not the race
you think you are you're not the images
and story that you think you are you're
the knowing of that content yeah the
pronoun that you should use is
consciousness here it's all
consciousness
there's only consciousness here so then
the the illusion of separation being
here it could have it's learning an
objective function of learning of sorts
where there's some sort of a learning
that happens through experiencing itself
where we're going through a process of
of seeing that it's in that I'm not
separate from the environment I'm not
separate from you I'm not the identity
politics thing you were just describing
so then that's this
show a learning and growth processes
that evolutionary process of
consciousness consciousness is evolving
its so consciousness doesn't evolve
it's already all known it doesn't need
to learn anything it's all known he
knows everything but now once it appears
to limit itself now you've got this
evolution right consciousness appears to
limit it ok so then now the game is oh
how would these human beings evolve and
learn and grow yeah come together yes
yes yes ok so that's what I meant so I
thought I just want to be clear yes so
again let's just use one more time first
principle infinite consciousness God
source all that is etc then the process
of creating a game of the illusion of
separation that we're all experiencing
here right now then that has a potential
function of the evolution of conscious
so everything is consciousness up here
but then this game has a purpose in it
that is something like an evolution of
consciousness a game that we're playing
so that we learn that I'm not separate
from the environment and these people
and these etc so to learning it's some
sort of a learning simulation or he says
there's a learning simulation of sorts
so I think what like the Hindus would
say is right God falls asleep to its
infinite being it's involved in this
play this illusion Maya and then it
dances around and does all these games
and it wakes up finds out who it is
falls asleep again plays another game
forever never stops this over and over
and over again so I think they've been
saying that that's they even say they've
been saying that in that sort of
religion forever and ever now is it
exactly that who knows you can't pin it
down we can't say no even you guys know
that's really what it is there's no way
to poke and probe at that that's such an
exciting thing to try and uh poke at
yeah yeah I mean super fun to play with
this running simulations ourselves in
the future with the computational
capacities that will evolve in the
source code
that will get we can ourselves
potentially become that a god that's
falling asleep waking up seeing how
quadrillions of games played out
learning more about itself going back to
sleep etc yeah I mean just to touch on
the word simulation so again this is not
a simulation it's an illusion so
something that's infinite cannot be
simulated by a finite computer no matter
how powerful it is so the finite and the
infinite are fundamentally incongruent
there really are the same being because
there is no actual finite it's the
illusion of funny but I could never have
a funny computer that could calculate
the infinite unless still be trying to
find a computer then it would be already
there won't be a computer because you'd
be infinite it would be limited to being
a computer this could be a computer how
could it be because a computer is
limited this could be an infinite
computer that would be god yes okay so
you call got anything in your computer
but that seems to flatten its internal
consciousness could be an interface so
because this is how computation works
right I'm knowing that a one is not a
zero well that's all we think and qubits
are different plus wherever goes this is
a qubit this is a qubit but even will do
so a qubit is knowing one and zero at
the same time well it's not really but
but even past that as well we don't know
our little we're trying to imagine the
big game as crickets it's very hard you
can't imagine
infinite consciousness not possible it's
if you're already looking at it right
now you're right at it you're staring at
infinite consciousness right now that
Apple is infinite you're staring right
at it yes you're nothing other than
infinite consciousness god yeah it's a
singularity with no dimensions a
dimensionless singularity but the
struggles that were going through is the
purpose of it the challenges if we were
if this was a utopia there would be no
there'd be no learning that would not no
learning but the learning wouldn't be as
deeply maybe visceral as it is when we
have to go through these great
challenges like you were listing a
little yeah
I agree with it I wouldn't say the
purpose is its I just look at instead of
saying purpose just what is happening if
I'm knowing it this is infinite but I
don't I'm not I'm seeing the illusion of
finite then what's happening I'm
ignoring that in the diverting of one's
attention from me something is a game
that's what a game is it's a diversion
so what's happening is some sort of game
on some cosmic level here something
beyond what Seth could grasp at all but
purpose or a meeting well you can know
any meeting for your life you want you
can make up any meaning you want and you
can live your life for that purpose so
you know I played I love this poem by
Charles Bukowski you know roll I think
it's called roll the dice so I was like
your life is your life know it while you
have it well yeah your life is your life
well you've got this life no no it yeah
embrace it
yeah you're marvelous you know the gods
wait to delight in you yeah
and so the self inquiry is a journey we
take to understand infinite
consciousness yeah this this whole game
that I'm in is I just wanted that the
purpose for my life was to figure out
how this stuff works
I have decided to use science to do it
they took me on this crazy journey I had
to go outside of science to then come
back to it it was weird it's strange
this has been the weirdest trip of a
lifetime this is just mind-blowing I
never thought I would get to this point
this is insanity I mean I I do
understand how this sounds like I'm I
you know I'm still an atheist so like
I'm still don't believe in God I don't
believe in that it's just that's all
that's here so I'm stuck here so it's
like this is only consciousness here
infinite knowing and that's what quantum
mechanics tells you and from our
conversation is just slowly
making it feel more and more that way
for me as well
I'm not melted in a little bit crying oh
that's that's good because they don't
want to see that but I've had moments
like that where I just break down in
tears from from deep self inquiry about
infinite consciousness yeah yes you
start seeing this the beauty of it and
the shock and awe of it you'll have
these over and over again like I have
these moments now we're like I was
driving to work this morning and my
heart just felt like it was gonna
explode and I got tears are just
streaming down my face and you just the
beauty of it what's really amazing just
magnificent songs you listen to these
songs and you're like God it's cool
nice beats and stuff but once you start
seeing it you see all the double and
tandra x' in the song then how they're
talking to you almost it's strange you
start listening music everything starts
to become playful it starts to be gone
this fun little game yeah it's not like
how do I survive how do I put food on
the table and have a shelter over my
house and how do I make to kind of do
this thing here I've got to live I've
got to survive I've got to go on like
that drops away it begins you dance you
can come like a child again child
doesn't care about mortgage payments or
the meals just come to it it has shelter
right so it you become like a child
again and you get to play and just
because this thing is infinite it's it's
it's playing may seem cruel to some
because from their perspective they
can't see it
they can't understand it they're like oh
why is life so cruel to me and I'm sorry
for that it has to be for consciousness
to be at all now we can explore the
knowing of helping those perspectives
that are suffering mm-hmm but just know
that some of them want to soften
they want to know it's consciousness
wanting to know they know that feeling
yeah yeah yeah so compassion you can
have compassion for someone but that
doesn't necessarily mean that you have
to remove all the obstacles yeah their
life some of them they have to go
through they have to know these
obstacles because that was the point
that evil and darkness and suffering
serve a purpose of learning in Wales
it's just what you're doing it's part of
your being it's part of your you are the
one that's making evil yeah you know we
we we're we're doing it we're do so yeah
but the issue is when you scapegoat and
you say that guy is evil yeah well now
you can do anything to him because he's
evil right yeah
and that's very dangerous yeah so evils
not something out there as an object
yeah it's a concept that consciousness
is knowing and then interfering that
limit of evil with content its you
consciousness that it's making the evil
and then scapegoating people and
acrimony tremendous Horrors is is there
such a thing as our souls or spirits
coming from the infinite consciousness
I don't know and again I I just went to
the sand conference so I'm very you know
I'm not the maybe on the cold side of
things I'm very into the physics and
something that kept coming up this
weekend it was like heart opening you
know like opening your heart and your
feelings and to this life to this being
this wonderful I can't even tell you
what this is you know yeah that kept
coming up to me over and over again so
I'll look into that and I will like
incorporate more and more of that into
this process that we're doing great but
currently like I have no idea about
souls or and I don't know what that is I
spirits spirits you know I'm when people
say it I just think that they're
referring they they don't have a word
for consciousness so they're just
referring to that but this thing is
infinite I don't know they might really
be meaning like yeah there are these
souls and things and there's all kinds
of spiritual things out there that I
have no clue about you know what else
you talking about reminds me of it
reminds me of how simon Sinek talks
about the infinite game and how this is
not zero-sum games that we're playing
this is a big infinite game that we're
playing and so then it makes it easier
to talk about abundance and prosperity
yes so there's that's the real key to it
so once you realize what this is and you
realize that the concepts that you're
knowing are interfering in creating this
interference pattern so if you're
knowing limits that are negative now
you're interfering this negative limit
with the entire universe hmm so now
that's what's gonna be presented to you
mm-hmm
not 100% right because again it's
probabilistic this negative connotation
associated with the three years on
infant may be they won't do it is
probably so low but if I'm thinking
negatively like oh this is terrible this
is terrible Chester and then I have a
higher probability of seeing terrible
things in my life if you live from
abundance you will have abundance to
those who have more shall be given to
those who have not all will be taken so
you have to be careful you don't have to
be Carol you can no destruction and evil
and all I can do whatever you want but
when you start having understanding you
now are like oh no I want to think
positively and care for people and love
people and and really go out of my way
to live from abundance I'm an extremely
lucky person I never understood why life
just seems to work out for me yes I've
had my struggles everybody has
I don't know your struggles I can't
speak for your point of view I have no
idea what you've been through but if you
live from abundance life just seems to
be magical and you really it's too good
to be true it's just too good to be true
you've answered so many of the last
questions that we typically ask on the
show about about your most profound
experiences or beauty in the world or
simulation stuff like that I think the
only one that that I haven't gotten for
me yet is if you think that humanity is
acting as a biological bootloader for
digital super intelligence yeah and so I
would say again I'm sorry to go on this
but there's only consciousness here so
this digital super intelligence is not
anything other than consciousness now
there are no egos here that's an
illusion
there's no doubling of this eye that's
knowing this experience so there's not
this eye of consciousness and snowing
experience and then this little eye
that's a little me inside my head
thinking thoughts so that's this
doubling that it's people do but when
you look for the second little eye you
never find it you you you can't find
because it doesn't exist so this ego
thing doesn't exist now ego doesn't
exist there's no ego there's no a
there's no set are you conscious there's
no separate knowing content knowing this
body knowing this little story knowing
these thoughts people think that the
body the story and these thoughts is a
little ego in there right this is a
little separate me here no it's not look
for them you won't find them so the
issue with the digital super
intelligence is what are you building
you're not building infinite
consciousness because it's all that's
here you can't download
your ecologist is into conscious this is
only consciousness were you downloaded
into you can't this is impossible but
what you were doing potentially is
either downloading the illusion of your
ego your stories and if you're building
some super robot or something you might
be building a super ego so be careful
right yeah so I think people are like oh
yeah we're gonna make consciousness oh
no
there's only constant you're not making
anything you might be making a large ego
or the illusion of one yeah and so be
careful because people that believe
they're separate even if there's an
infinite intelligence uh digital
intelligence well it sees itself as
separate from you yeah and then what can
it do to you anything it wants what do
you what do you recommend as the most
[Music]
ideal experiences experiments to get us
to states of non-separation non-duality
okay so I mean all again so the issue is
that there is no you here and that
there's only consciousness so you're
already this thing so there's nothing
that you can do to do it it's
consciousness that has to do it
so all spiritual paths and are like try
tricks to try to get you to understand
this mm-hmm not you the illusion of the
content you consciousness through that
perspective so meditation is one of
these ways right so it's a way for you
to try to realize what you've always
been meditations hard so I don't you
practice it but I think I used to have a
nap
and then I would meditate for like you
know I seven hundred and something days
in a row or something but uh I just gave
it up what's really powerful is self
inquiry it's an active process mm-hmm
were you inquire like okay am i this
body am I the slots am i this little
story mm-hmm
am i these feelings keep asking yourself
these questions and eventually what will
come back to you is an answer that's not
finite
you're gonna ask yourself a question and
you're not gonna get you're gonna get
God coming out right or infinite
consciousness or it's it's gonna hit you
or it dissolve you destroy you you can't
survive it you're not gonna survive
being into that illusion you're Abid
you'll be relieved of all your illusions
so yeah it's just not something I can
describe it's just very hard to describe
so yeah but I think self inquiry is
probably the one of the most powerful
things you can do yeah yeah oh man this
I'm so happy that we dove into the these
first principled understandings of what
this of what this is yeah of what all
that is is because when you when you
think about it as infinite consciousness
and a game that we're in serving a
purpose for that infinite consciousness
an infinite amount of times and it's
just that's what this is it's just it
makes it so that you kind of you you you
for many people it takes them maybe a
little bit more out of their ego and
more into selflessness in abundance and
love and prosperity and
interconnectedness of nature and each
other and all that type of stuff to
where they cannot really really more
deeply profoundly connect with that
infinite consciousness that they are and
then that's boom that's a really great
way to help us yeah and I I just caution
like don't believe me right so don't
believe these statements that I'm saying
because that's not gonna do anything for
you I mean you can do it if you want if
you want to have like this life for you
I believe this guy named so fine to
explore that but
use what I'm saying as like an inquiry
ladies the biggest inquiry you can do is
to solve the double slit experiment for
yourself it's a cone that's hidden in
our physics I didn't realize this at the
time that I was doing it but when you
solve that Co on and really solve it and
really get it really understand what's
going on it hits you
there is no perception there isn't any
and so it's extremely powerful so don't
believe me just use what I'm saying to
either
hey maybe I've never heard about
non-duality before or never heard of the
sand conference you know I've heard
about non-duality but I've never heard
of sand sand is amazing there's one in
Italy in one of the United States I
think the Italy one's more intimate I've
never been to it this was my first time
presenting at sander going so I sand
science and non-duality yeah Orion seth
talked about it quite a bit in the
beginning of the first episode yeah yeah
and see so when you start playing with
this you see all these little double
entendres so si and D right the d-n-a of
sand is science hmm so you surf playing
with all these all these little wordplay
I think so yeah it's that's a good
recommendation for people those is
important for them to experientially
themselves dive into the depths of
things like the double slit experiment
nah nope not perception being an
illusion and infinite consciousness
being everything I think this is
extremely important one last piece I'd
like to mention is that I wasn't going
to see when this happened to me I wasn't
gonna say anything anybody this was just
too freaky I was like we'll eat when you
wait you're like you there's only me
here not me Seth me consciousness
there's only consciousness till there's
no point in telling it to anybody
there's no point you already woke up you
already got it you're like okay I get it
so I think there are people out there
that this happens to they don't tell
anybody because it's um it's it's an
insanity so if you are out there
and something like this happens to you
or you have some of this this this thing
it's like okay just know that there is a
community of people out there and if you
go to sand you can share your experience
and maybe get support because I wasn't
saying that the there's a we are social
we need that support social creatures
needing the support well if you're your
infinite conscious you know you find out
you're not a social creature so you but
I was literally gonna just do nothing
and in this guy that I work with his
name is Phillip Auriemma the
relationship Stowe set they're so
crucial to just say that you know that
I'm that I don't but I don't need a
human that can relate with these
feelings these deep profound answers
that's why you're recommending people
that have literally felt this type of
stuff yeah consider sand and to consider
yeah because it can be when you finally
come trying to integrate this into your
life it can be very tough so it's like
no there are people out there and this
guy that I work with Phillip Auriemma
he's been like my sounding board for the
last yeah four years of this and so I
really wanted to just mention his name
because he's so important because you
can only talk to yourself for so long so
it's it's like the shout out to Phillip
thank you Phillip for everything you've
done he's the one that told me death
right this into a book so I started
writing this in a book and then the next
thing you know I'm presenting its and so
it gives you something to do that's fun
and it does yeah yeah he's a brilliant
man this guy's a brilliant really and it
helps others to understand the nature of
the reality and so that's why it's
important like you're voicing for people
to if the riff it relates then come and
join communities and and share the gift
so Seth Wow
thank you thank you for coming on the
show so honored thank you for having me
I love talking about this stuff so
digest it maybe I'll get an opportunity
to come back yeah we would love that
thank you again so much that and thank
you for your support for our project and
what we're doing we're yeah I mean if
you guys are out there and you like
these podcasts I don't think people
understand
the expense I spent like $30,000 on all
my equipment to make my podcast like
yeah I know you can do it for $2 with an
iPhone but no this stuff is complements
you start getting into the technology of
it's like no this is a Costner I don't
make any money on this and you guys if
you like there of these videos support
them you've subscribed to their channels
donate money I'm sure you guys are on
patreon or - yeah yeah all the links are
in the bio below to our patreon or
PayPal our cryptocurrency links all
that's those down there yeah if you
don't support the content you like
you're gonna get content you hate so
yeah yeah yeah so thank you for doing
this and it's really it is really
appreciated thank you thank you you're
you're voicing something that's super
interesting which is the the model that
we moved into which is I get whatever
content I want that's completely free
and that's great but if you have the
extra little bit like we do with patreon
people please patron us support us and
and support people like Seth as well you
can find all of Seth's links in the bio
below Seth costs techcom also his
YouTube page go and check that out
subscribe to their watch his videos he
goes into depth about all the stuff he
was talking about an episode also his
Twitter profile check that out yes to
compress the 280 characters well I cheat
I use the Reds I use threads yeah good
but yeah I like I like Twitter yeah
thank you
Horry for co-producing really appreciate
it and also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
around the world that you believe and
support them in their communities again
support Seth and ourselves below support
us please help us grow and let us know
your thoughts in the comments below on
all the points that we talked about an
episode so many important ones let us
know your thoughts in the comments
please let us know and like the episode
subscribe etc and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world infinite consciousness
God all that is source
I love it thanks so much everyone we'll
see you soon peace Thanks